not all horror franchises are created
equal and some are so perfectly crafted
that they're just begging for a scary
movie marathon
from slasher films the killer dull
flicks to sci-fi series
here are the best scary movie franchises
to binge watch
certain horror franchises just burn
through sequels at a ridiculous pace
churning out cookie cutter films that
all feel basically the same
but in the case of halloween this series
went in a different direction
having first started in 1978 the
halloween saga spans
over four decades of storytelling
drawing which had seen several different
filmmakers and aesthetics
meanwhile halloween three season of the
witch even abandoned michael myers
altogether in an attempt to turn the
franchise into an anthology series
watching all the halloween movies will
take you on a wild ride from john
carpenter's original take on michael
myers
to the self-referential tomfoolery of
later entries like halloween
resurrection
which co-starred buster rhymes consuming
all movies in this franchise also
inevitably means partaking in rob
zombies brutal reboots and david gordon
green's recent reimagining of the series
basically trying to keep any track of
any semblance of coherent mythology
across these movies
is a false errand however seeing so many
radically different takes on the
halloween universe
makes diving into this franchise a total
treat
freddy krueger may haunt your nightmares
but for horror fans the nightmare movies
are the stuff dreams are made of
starting with wes craven's iconic 1984
original nightmare on elm street the
franchise took full advantage of the
fact that most of these films take place
in people's dreams
resulting in some truly amazing scares
the visual component became even more
noticeable in later instalments
which got more and more ridiculous in
depicting how kruger could kill in the
domain of dreams
[Music]
welcome to wonderland
not every entry in this series is an
instant classic but the persistently
unique kills and the sequels that
embrace
truly unusual plots made the franchise
an expansive canvas worth diving into
and some fans of the nightmare series
might even enjoy the 2010 remake
featuring jackie l haley's chilling take
on freddy krueger
when the first evil dead movie came out
it wasn't supposed to kick off a
long-running franchise
it was just a low-budget horror movie by
passionate newbie filmmaker sam raimi
but after it took off as a cult classic
this charmingly ramshackle horror movie
spawned further films that took the
series in different directions
evil dead 2 utilized the basic setup of
the original
but amped up every aspect making use of
its bigger budget
it also added a whole lot of comedy to
the horror later army of darkness took
just the ash character for a largely
standalone fantasy adventure
involving the middle ages
this is my boomstick
much later 2013's the evil dead
reimagined the basic concept of
youngsters in an abandoned cabin
and added a level of tangible and brutal
reality to the proceedings
there isn't much consistency across the
evil dead movies but that's what makes
the series so interesting
this is especially true in regards to
the first three in which you can watch
raymie growing with confidence as a
filmmaker in real time
but if there's one consistency across
these movies it's the presence of great
moments of gross-out horror
binge-watching the evil dead series will
doubtlessly satisfy all your cravings
from bashir lee ridiculous horror cinema
when the child's play movie started
nobody involved could have imagined
where the series would go
if you plan to watch all the child's
play movies though buckle up
because the trajectory of this series is
a wild one watching them consecutively
means viewers will start in the 1980s
before moving into 21st century
installments
like seed of chucky that took things
into unexpected avenues
these later films saw the blood flowing
as well as the creative juices of don
mancini
who wrote all of the chucky flakes and
directed the last three
hi are you my favorite pet my buddy
[Music]
binge watching just the first five
child's play installments would make for
a fantastically memorable experience
however avid fans of the franchise could
also throw in the two direct-to-video
sequels overseen by mancini
as well as experience an alternate
version of chucky through the
surprisingly enjoyable 2019
child's play remake watching the series
will take viewers on a roller coaster of
different tones filmmaking styles
and even incarnations of chucky voiced
by the legendary brad doreth and mark
hamill respectively
sure no one expected such a journey back
when this killer doll first started
carving up trouble
all of that unexpectedness though is a
gain of horror movie binge watchers
everywhere the sword movies like any
torture horror series will not be to
everyone's taste
some people enjoy watching the creative
ways these movies keep coming up with
for characters to write in agony
but for others it's just not their cup
of tea if this is your go-to form of
horror entertainment though then saw is
an ideal fit for a knight of horror
binge watching
and in an unexpected move for a slew of
micro budget sequels
later saw installments established a
dense lore for this universe
jigsaw was no longer just a killer for
example by the end of saw three he
became a deceased
mastermind who left behind convoluted
ways to keep his legacy going
the details of this franchise only get
more and more bizarre from there
as the source sequels constantly expand
upon their mythos
even as recently as 2021's spiral
watching them all back to back can be
the ideal way to pick up on all the
pieces of connective tissue between
individual
entries and the constant presence of new
ways for jigsaw and his proteges to kill
people
can keep the entertainment going the
purge movies don't begin on the highest
note
the original installment from 2013 is
the least ambitious entry in the series
despite the presence of notable actors
like ethan hawke
but the film proved successful enough to
spawn a trio of follow-ups
that have each gotten more confident
than the last even better they've all
featured different lead actors
and for the most part individual purge
movies have opted to focus on new
characters
this inclination has expanded in the
most recent installments
to include focusing on very specific
minority perspectives
such as black heroes and the first purge
and latinx characters in the forever
perch
the increasing variety and confidence in
each subsequent purge movie
culminated in the franchise's best entry
yet the first perch
which saw the series dive headfirst into
enjoyably blunt political commentary
absorbing these titles in a binge
watching fashion allows viewers to
appreciate how this series has evolved
from its inaugural entry as it adds new
characters and begins to explore the
titular knight
from the perspective of various
marginalized groups plus watching these
films in release order
allows your binge watch to cap off on a
high note just grit your teeth through
the original perch and this franchise
can make for a mighty fine horror
marathon
there's no masks killer wandering
through the various final destination
movies the antagonist here is just the
presence of death itself
death doesn't like to be cheated and
each final destination movie sees death
managing to find creative ways to kill
its young victims
the five entries in this franchise have
gotten varying degrees of reception from
critics and audiences
but none of them were short on
imaginative ways of ending the lives of
their principal characters
the fact that each new movie keeps
bringing in a new crop of characters to
kill off helps lend a sense of
distinctiveness to each entry
similarly the lack of a personified
presence for death across
multiple features means that the villain
of the funnel destination films never
loses its sense of menace
this is in sharp contrast to other
horror foes like jason voorhees
who stick around for multiple movies and
end up becoming punchlines
i can beat you the conjuring franchise
is one of the few consistently
successful cinematic universes without a
marvel studios logo attached to it
starting in 2013 with the conjuring the
series has gone on to spawn not just two
direct follow-ups but also a trio of
annabelle spin-offs as well as further
offshoots with the nun
and the curse of la lorona though the
spin-offs largely work as standalone
movies they do find ways of connecting
or referring to the main conjuring
titles
such as the ending of the nun which
reveals how one of the film's characters
influence the very existence of the
original conjuring
fully appreciating these kinds of
connections is one of several rewards
you can glean from digesting the various
conjuring installments
in a binging mode another website is
examining what different directors bring
to this franchise
the playful nature of david f samberg's
annabelle creation for example
is starkly different from the haunted
house vibes of james one's first two
conjuring movies
though they all like you by the same
space there are different atmospheres
and even time periods
explored in the various conjuring titles
giving us one of the rare cinematic
universes to thrive at the box office
the world of international horror is
vast and dense with phenomenal titles
however if you're specifically in the
mood for a series of long-running
foreign language horror films to binge
watch
one of your best options is the juwon
series the inspiration behind the
american crutch franchise
the original japanese series has got you
covered when it comes to incredibly
creepy films
for example if you're in the mood for
only a quartet of films you can simply
partake in the original series of juwon
films that ended with the pair of 2009
features
black ghost and white ghost however
there are plenty of other installments
in this franchise
if you're craving more juwon frights if
you want to be a completist though
you'll also have to include the
crossover event movie juwon vs ringo
which brings together the demonic
entities from the original grudge
and ring movies no franchise that gets
to sixth installments or eight if you
want to count the alien vs predator
crossover features
can deliver classic movies all of the
time however this series still delivered
two stone cold masterpieces with its
first two films alien and aliens
across these two entries the most
beloved staples of the franchise were
established while also showing a
refreshing refusal to just repeat the
past
while alien is a darker horror movie
aliens has a rollicking action adventure
that particular quality can be chalked
up to the different directors for each
movie
with ridley scott helming the first
alien and james cameron directing the
sequel
after aliens equality gets a lot less
consistent but that doesn't mean the
rest of the franchise is devoid of merit
for one thing it's fascinating to watch
how ridley scott's 21st century alien
movies
like prometheus compared to his very
first title for another divisive
features like alien 3 may not be
universally loved but they could be up
your alley
that's the joy of binge watching a
series like alien not every film will be
your favorite but you could find an
unexpected gem within the franchise
with night of the living dead in 1967
george a romero forever altered zombies
slow walking undead figures that devour
human flesh are commonplace in pop
culture today
but romero defined our modern conception
of these beasts with a single film
this accomplishment alone makes his
original knight to the living dead a
landmark horror film
but romero didn't stop there he created
a slew of sequels that provide the
perfect basis
for a frightening round of binge
watching while many horror sequels to
famous films are low-grade cash grabs
several of the knight of the living dead
follow-ups are acclaimed movies in their
own right
particularly the 1978 installment dawn
of the dead
not only does watching this series
provide you with plenty of beloved
zombie fare
but it's also intriguing to take in the
unique qualities of each entry
since romero made most of the movies in
different decades many of the films have
a unique ambience that reflects the
atmosphere of horror cinema in that era
for example 2007's diary of the dead was
the first near resurgent wave of found
footage movies in the late 2000s
a sharp contrast to the more
conventional filming techniques in the
original night of the living dead
romero's zombie films gave fans as much
food for thought as it does graphic
zombie kills
and that makes them perfect movie night
material check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one